i'm walking with my girl kelly
and um shout out to kelly kelly and
kabowski
no nope nope uh but she's later
nope nope nope kelly slater the surfer
was back when she
he was a girl and uh i'm in hoboken
new jersey walking after dinner and
three young ruffians
let's call them they were probably i was
23 and they were 18
maybe even 17 maybe 14. no no
but they were they were older i'll tell
you why i know that so the guy goes
the guy goes uh man i'll [ __ ] your girl
and i go i go um can't have that
wait were you guys just walking by yeah
and he's right mouth [ __ ] yo girl i
stopped and i turned
out dude [ __ ] your girl for me again let
me figure out that message
go [ __ ] your girl so back to the story
of those some of the most beautiful
these
were a chirping they might have been
puerto rican they might you know but
then again you know they could be a mix
of things but anyway so
by the way they're they're kids and uh
and i come back i turn around and i go
what'd you say about my girl
and he goes i won't say anything about
girl man he's looking down
he goes because uh
i go all right and i i walk in he goes
but i'll [ __ ] your girl
now i turn back around and i go you're
talking to me now
and he goes whatever shoes move on move
on shoes
move on shoes i had a pair of uh
black shoes and back then i would always
wear black shoes and i preferred with a
steel toe
boot steel toe and uh soles i could get
some
traction on i know so i could kick oh
okay i was taekwondo guy remember okay
wrestler taekwondo guy i know you
laughed
but this is my street fight you go much
oh well dude i'm not big see what
happens is i'm gonna keep going you
understand i'm i'm a hot head because
but he called you shoes based off these
black
boots yeah i think they were shoes they
weren't even boots if i remember they
were shoes
so anyway i think they were like they
were like doc martens but not doc
martens because i didn't like doc
martens because skinhead words
blah blah so anyway so uh
he calls me shoes and then
i kicked him and i kicked him
i tried to kick him in the face like
you're a hot head man i kind of made his
shoes
well no no because you're saying i'm
gonna [ __ ] your girl
i know but that's what you tried to keep
on shoes
and then um and then i i kicked i knew
he was
[ __ ] with me because he was talking
to my girl and i kicked him in the face
i didn't quite hit him in the face i
think i hit him in the shoulder long
story short he
jumps on me and grabs me around the
waist and now i'm punching him
in the head can't hurt him yeah i can't
hurt him nolan rhymes though
yeah but i'm not hurting him i'm hitting
him and i'm and then
his two buddies are circling me but
they're not hitting them
one kid tries to hit me i kind of duck
it's very awkward nobody's tough here
okay
i think it's a [ __ ] fest it's a [ __ ]
fest it's a sesame street now a woman
a girl who's one of their friends come
here goes i remember never forget it she
goes
how old are you how old are you sir as
i'm beating these kids up
okay but they're 18. so [ __ ] those don't
think they were i'm trying to kill the
kids definitely weren't
they were 13 but no definitely not 13.
you were 20.
they were they were up they were both my
size the two kids were tall smaller
long story short now now i'm trying to
punch this guy and i'm kidding
i can't hurt him yeah the kids all i
can't hurt him
a cop comes running up i get away from
the kid
i get away from the kid throw another
kick
kind of miss don't roll his back
and i wasn't old i was 23. i didn't say
i didn't go sikka take that puerto rican
is like dude what is this
i wasn't old i was a young tight-skinned
pewdiepie
two weeks ago sir about three weeks ago
now listen